[Musique]
bonsoir merci de nous rejoindre pour
cette nouvelle édition de votre journal
d'information locale voici les titres de
ce 19 janvier 2017 le froid un perdure
avec des températures toujours glaciales
malgré un soleil présent tout au long de
la journée dans les yvelines et ce froid
ne devrait pas lâcher prise avant lundi
nos conseils pour faire face une
nouvelle double exposition à la
commanderie des templiers c'est à
elancourt arts visuels et sciences
dialogue autour de la notion de textile
et puis de la musique baroque avec le
projet génération lully un parcours
artistique autour d'ateliers et de
rencontres pour les habitants de trappes
mais aussi les élèves de l'école de la
deuxième chance et cette information
économique pour débuter safran dont le
siège social est basé à vélizy vient
d'annoncer son ambition de fusionner
avec zodiac aerospace pour former un
leader mondial de l'aéronautique
la fusion de ces deux groupes français
permettrait de créer le numéro deux
mondial des équipements aéronautiques
une acquisition de près de 10 milliards
d'euros dans l'actualité locale
également les voeux du maire de
villepreux stéphane mirambeau a fait ses
voeux à la population vendredi dernier
il en a profité pour dévoiler les grands
projets pour cette nouvelle année
programme pour 2010 cette révision du
plan local d'urbanisme
ce sera d'ici au mois de juin pour
agrandir la commune travaux également du
quartier des eaux du moulin pour le
groupe scolaire ce sera pour le mois de
septembre est l'élu est enfin revenu sur
l'intégration de villepreux à la
communauté d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines intégration
qui s'est faite en janvier à de l'année
dernière et coûté le set au micro de
michael et demi d'eau moi j'ai toujours
été très très claires j'ai été élu par
les villes provient et mon rôle de
numéro un
c'est de défendre les intérêts de
villepreux mais je peux tout à fait
concevoir que les intérêts de saint
quentin les arbitres soient les mêmes
donc on va aller se battre là dessus
mais je reste avant tout est évidemment
mais je crois comme tous les maires des
douze communes chaque maire est avant
tout présent parce qu'il a été élu dans
sa ville et il se bat évidemment pour sa
ville et il se bat aussi ensemble pour
saint quentin de villepreux à magny les
hameaux à présent depuis le 31 décembre
l'antenne des jardins de cocagne a fermé
ses portes la structure produisait et
des légumes biologiques locaux pour les
particuliers elle évoque des problèmes
financiers des aides régionales et
départementales en forte baisse
néanmoins une réouverture du côté de
trappes en partenariat avec les actes de
la marsa vent c'est un établissement est
de service et dead par le travail ce
rapprochement est évoqué avec la commune
pour ouvrir lé jardin de cocagne donc à
la cocagne pardon donc à trappes
mais qu'en pense le maire de magny les
hameaux la réponse au micro de nicolas
kirillovitch je trouve cela dommage
parce que on a beaucoup oeuvré au niveau
de la commune de magny les hameaux pour
les accueillir sur ce territoire
précieux on croit autant à l'insertion
par le travail qu au maraîchage bio de
proximité et à l'action finalement d'un
emploi qui est qui peut être pérennisé
en local et qui n'est pas délocalisable
on a même payé certains outils un jardin
de cocagne dans son installation
on a tout fait pour permettre
l'installation dessert aujourd'hui tout
ce que j'espère c'est qu'on puisse
trouver une structure qui reprennent ce
projet d'agriculture du haut de
proximité dans le même esprit d'économie
sociale et solidaire dont le même esprit
de proximité dans le cadre de la
viabilité hivernale les agents du
département sont particulièrement
attentif au risque d'épisode neigeux et
verglaçant ils interviennent
régulièrement en préventif ou en curatif
précision de maxime le même avec ce
reportage réalisé pour le conseil
départemental des yvelines pour leurs
déplacements dans le département les
yvelinois privilégie majoritairement la
voiture quelles que soient les
conditions climatiques
les équipes du conseil départemental
entretiennent quotidiennement les routes
afin de garantir la sécurité des usagers
ainsi même en cas d'épisode neigeux ou
verglaçants les automobilistes peuvent
circuler sur les routes départementales
nous surveillons la météo on a un site
dédié dans le cadre d'un marché public
avec météo france qui nous permet de
pouvoir anticiper tout épisode
météorologique qui aurait une incidence
sur les routes vendredi 13 janvier le
département a connu un bref épisode
neigeux 27 agents étaient mobilisés du
côté de rambouillet thierry et ses
collègues ont été prévenus la veille
ils ont ainsi pu préparer leur saleuses
et rentrer chez eux
un peu plus tôt pour revenir vers 4
heures du matin un rythme pas toujours
facile on rentre à 17h30 et ensuite
jusqu'à 2 heures du matin il faut dormir
un peu parce que nous on travaille quand
même sur le domaine public dehors comme
la ne serait-ce que hier on a coupé des
arbres on a ramassé des branches avec
des conditions météo c'est l'hiver c'est
pas évident
chaque conducteur parcourt environ 140
kilomètres pendant trois heures
de telle sorte que la route soit
praticable pour les usagers qui partent
travailler dès 7 heures du matin depuis
le 14 novembre début de la viabilité
hivernale les agents d'astreinte sont
régulièrement sorti pour des opérations
de salage préventive ou curative la
moitié du stock de sel commandé pour la
période a déjà été utilisé nous
continuons avec un sujet de saison
depuis plusieurs jours vous l'avez
ressenti le froid s'est abattu sur le
département les températures sont
souvent négatives et cette vague de
froid pourrait entraîner une
surconsommation énergétique qui pourrait
représenter jusqu'à 30% comment éviter
cette surconsommation les explications
avec vous haussmann l'an dernier eh bien
comment éviter la surconsommation tout
d'abord il faut éviter d'utiliser son
four ou encore le lave linge ou
l'aspirateur pendant les heures de
pointe ce qui est entre 17h et 20h
ne pas laisser vos appareils en veille
la roux parle de la télé des ordinateurs
ou encore de votre portable des
appareils en veille représente 11 % de
la facture annuelle d'un consommateur
et puis surtout ne pas surchauffer sa
maison quand vous n'êtes pas chez vous
il faut laisser la température à 14
degrés une fois que vous revenez il faut
l'augmenter jusqu'à 19 degrés et puis
une note en plus
éteignez la lumière quand vous n'êtes
pas dans vos yeux dans la salle alors
aussi quand vous êtes à l'extérieur
qu'est ce qu'il faut faire il faut
protéger toutes les extrémités de votre
corps c'est-à-dire la tête léman ou
encore les pieds avec un bonnet des
gants et des très bonnes chaussures il
faut aussi usé de la technique de
l'oignon c'est à dire acheter en gros un
gros pull cela ne sert pas à grand chose
il faut avoir plusieurs couches et des
couches qui sont près du corps et puis
c'est un point important il faut bien
s'alimenter on y pense rarement mais il
faut prendre des produits comme des
légumes ou encore des fruits c'est à
dire avoir de la vitamine c est beaucoup
mangé beaucoup de pâtes et de riz et 6
durant cette période de grand froid vous
voyez des personnes qui sont sans abri
n'hésitez pas à contacter le samu
c'est le numéro le numéro c'est le 115
pour ses différentes précision on
retiendra donc cette technique de
l'oignon pour ne pas avoir froid vous
poursuivants en tout cas présent cette
édition avec l'occasion de rester bien
au chaud vous avez des tensions au
travail de la fatigue musculaire un
muscle froissé et bien sachez que les
techniques de massage ont la cote en ce
moment nous sommes partis à la rencontre
d'ariel savoyen elle dirige l'atelier de
massage cinquième sens c'est à
versailles le sujet de à mathilde de
demi avec camille lambert
ambiance tamisée et chaude éclairée à la
bougie musique douce
ariel savoyen apaise les mots de ses
patients cette voyageuse transmet son
savoir à travers le massage est donc à
chaque fois je me faisais ma c thaïlande
vietnam
enfin dans vraiment dans beaucoup
d'endroits et à chaque fois en effet je
me faisait masser
parce que j'aime vraiment ça et je me
rappelle toujours d'une fois c'est en
thaïlande où je me suis fait masser et
ça remonte à je dirais 20 ans à peu près
et quand la personne hamas et je me suis
dit je rêverais de faire ce qu'elle fait
j'ai créé l'atelier de massage en 2011
en février 2011 donc ça va bientôt faire
six ans on est à versailles celle à
versailles un échange un geste un
mouvement et une énergie
c'est ce que communique ariel savoyen
durant ces séances avec ses mains elle
décèle chaque tension cachet plus plus
on masse plus on se rend compte des
tensions des personnes de mon shoot
c'est le sport qu'elles peuvent
pratiquer on peut s'en rendre compte
aussi par la musculature et puis et puis
surtout vous avez à chaque fois
différents et ça c'est super amateurs ou
d'un client régulier ariel savoillans
s'adapte aux patients et propose
différents types de massages alors vous
allez massage californien qui est le
massage plus enveloppants et le plus
facile à recevoir je dirais qu'ils
s'adaptent vraiment au gré des besoins
de la personne
après vous avez le massage ayurvédique
qui est un massage d'origine indienne
qui régule les énergies qui s'appuie sur
la médecine les joueurs vedaquais la
médecine indienne via le massage
balinais fameux x massage un cinquième
sens qu'elle a développée et qui a porté
ses fruits
ariel savoyen est en train d'ouvrir un
nouveau salon un pari à découvrir en
février prochain
nous quittons versailles pour saint
quentin en yvelines la saison culturelle
est placée sous le signe du futur après
l'espace en novembre 2016 c'est le
textile le fils qui est décrypté dans
deux nouvelles expositions
vous allez découvrir une passion une
amour des fils d'arlette vers mais rien
ce qui s'entremêlent ses fils qui
s'entremêlent c'est sa deuxième
exposition elle se concentre sur
l'innovation et sur la création regarder
ce sujet de mélanie poquet des fils qui
se lit qui centre nous arlette vermeren
les faits elle même et les transforment
en oeuvre l'amour des fils est un virus
qu'elle a attrapé
je les ai toujours eu pourquoi parce que
j'avais une mère qui faisait de la haute
couture
g
mon enfant a baigné dans les tissus donc
je pense que j'ai pris ce virus et j'ai
toujours été passionné tout d'un coup je
suis parti en récupérant tout ce qui me
tombait sous la main et de petites
choses je suis arrivé je travaille comme
vous voyez vraiment d'être et candeur
des oeuvres monumentales par scarlett
vers murray n'aime pas travailler petits
mais aussi des pièces plus discrètes ou
l'artiste joue sur le tissu
vestimentaire un textile parfois
futuristes comme ceux de cette jeune
designer et ses t-shirts brodé avec des
fils conducteurs
je travaille sur l'aspect génératif du
coup du vêtement donc le l'interaction
n'a pas de fonction en fait ici dans le
dans le projet il n'a que pour but de
montrer en fait une esthétique le
le concept aussi c'est travailler sur du
court un artisanat numérique donc
vraiment l'intégration en fait de
l'électronique de manière du coup manuel
hydrophobe anti-ondes antipollution le
vêtement se décline sous plusieurs
formes des pièces que l'on pourrait
porter dans un avenir proche
depuis le mois d'octobre le centre de
musique baroque de versailles s'est
lancé dans le projet génération lully
c'est un parcours artistique autour
d'ateliers de rencontres pour permettre
aux habitants de trappes de découvrir la
musique baroque dans ce cadre également
cinq stagiaires de l'école de la
deuxième chance son parti à malte pour
suivre la création d'une pièce ils sont
revenus dimanche dernier et nous sommes
allés recueillir leurs impressions
camille lambert depuis septembre
angélique étudie à l'école de la
deuxième chance de trappes
elle revient tout juste d'un voyage à
malte organisé par le centre de musique
baroque de versailles
elle a pu découvrir la création de la
pièce atys en folie un univers qui lui
était jusque là inconnu cet effort à
découvrir la musique baroque donc sur un
spectacle parodique avec orchestre
baroque en fait j'avais jamais assisté
de façon une pièce de théâtre ont plus
rien même pas le concert mois en fait
c'était vraiment le voyage plein de
découvertes cinq stagiaires se sont
envolés direction le festival de musique
baroque à la valette
un voyage mené dans le cadre de
génération lully ce projet pédagogique
initié en octobre 2016 a pour mission de
sensibiliser les trappistes à l'art
baroque de travail de toute l'équipe qui
a travaillé ce qui faisait les décors on
avait les marines et est aussi cerise on
crée on avait des costumières les
maquilleuses des coiffeuses
on a rarement vu le spectacle en fait de
l'intérieur on empanne d'extérieur et
virginia c'est un univers qu'ils ne
connaissent pas forcément donc c'est à
dire faire découvrir des choses qu'ils
n'ont pas l'habitude de voir et de
l'autre côté de pas perdre de vue aussi
la partie professionnelle
une des exigences par rapport au travail
le travail en équipe
le savoir être des choses qui dont ils
vont avoir besoin on va dire mon leur
futur lors de leur futur métier
ce voyage aura même susciter des
vocations musicales depuis lors autour
angelica hicks état envisage de débuter
l'apprentissage d'un instrument
après la première mondiale a mal tati
sans folie sera présenté à la maurice de
trappes le 2 mars
c'est la fin de ce journal demain
vendredi vous avez rendez vous avec un
nicolas kirillovitch pour le 7-8 hebdo
l'essentiel de la semaine commentée par
son invité excellente soirée sur notre
antenne
[Musique]